[Music]
hi my name is Mike Trudy
I'm a cloud technical curriculum
developer for Google cloud learning and
this is Dan Sullivan who's a principal
engineer and software architect in his
day job
Dan's also the author of the recently
published official Google cloud
certified associate cloud engineer study
guide we think there's never been a
better time for you all the Google cloud
certified and we're here to tell you how
to do it using the paths programs and
tools provided by Google cloud there's a
whole bushel basket of information we
have for you
so let's get started here I'm gonna try
to give you an overview of our
certification process and then Dan's
gonna give you a little bit of a deep
dive using the associate cloud engineer
certification to help guide you for some
strategy on how to get certified with
concrete examples finally we're gonna
point you at a whole bunch of resources
and offers we have available here at
cloud NEX so you're here at next 19and
and I know you're as excited as I am
about everything getting announced and
we know businesses are moving to Google
cloud platform to add more value whether
it's in meeting your existing needs or
inventing your future and to support you
Google has created two different
certification levels associate and
professional within these levels Google
offers one associate certification and
five professional certifications the two
different levels provide different entry
points for engineers with varying
degrees of experience and I'm going to
explain that in a little bit more detail
in a minute the different certifications
that we offer map to different critical
job roles all contributing in important
ways and we have an associate cloud
engineer a professional cloud architect
a professional data engineer
professional cloud developer
professional network engineer and our
newest certification of the professional
security engineer and we're offering our
first public testing for the security
engineer certification here at NEX
I encourage you all to go to cloud goo
komm certifications and explore if you
remember nothing else from us today
that's probably the best thing for you
to take away is that link right there so
so why certify to be sure there are many
reasons to get certified it's not
horrible and we've heard this from many
sources that becoming google cloud
certified can increase your earning
power and I can tell you from personal
experience LinkedIn that I get a lot
more attention now that I've been cloud
certified so that's pretty nice
also since cloud is about moving past
traditional IT and unlocking new
paradigms of work we know many
businesses are facing a severe shortage
of skilled labor and certifications are
a reasonable method organization used to
validate baseline capabilities with a
new way of working being Google cloud
certified means you've demonstrated the
necessary skills to leverage Google
technology in a way that can transform
businesses quoting from IT skills
surveys overall decision makers reported
that certified team members troubleshoot
issues and complete projects more
quickly and have fewer skills gaps and
here's where we can introduce training
we know training is separate but
supportive of certification and training
is absolutely associated with job
satisfaction so this second link
cloud.google.com assess training is
where we describe all the different
offers that Google has for training
along multiple learning paths the
learning paths are each mapped to a
different certification so the learning
paths that include cloud infrastructure
data and machine learning application
development and so on we also offer for
training different learning environments
to customize the training for whatever
you like or need we have on-demand
courses where you can learn online at
your own pace wherever you are or you
can get matched with Google cloud
instructors and classroom instruction
which frequently works better for larger
groups but perhaps the most valuable
kind of training experience that we have
is hands-on training and for this we
have quick labs hands-on quests and labs
quick labs are easy to work through
guided tours of the capabilities needed
to be successful in these job tasks and
job roles so this week here in the dev
zone we have a couple of different lab
experiences that we'll talk about a
little later I want to dive just a
little bit deeper into a question we get
asked frequently which is what is the
difference between the associate level
certifications and the professional
level certifications and one way we
distinguish between them is the
associate cloud engineer is a job task
based certification and the professional
level certifications are job role based
job task versus job role a job task
based certification is focused on
technologies and tools that's sort of an
a good spot for people who are trying to
find an entry point into cloud or even
into GCP and it's also a great pathway
to our professional certifications and
in this case we can see that for
Associate cloud engineer we use verbs
like build and deploy and manage because
the job tasks for that associate cloud
engineer are usually centered around
translating technical requirements into
technical details in implementations and
that's different than our professional
certification which adds a couple of
different verbs like design plan and
optimize and it usually takes many years
to acquire the experience necessary with
the ambiguities of real-world problems
and hands-on work to develop the
abilities we look for translating
business requirements to the technical
requirements needed by a professional
that's different than what we consider
in the associate level now specifically
to dive a little deeper there are proven
strategies to guide you whether you're
pursuing associate or professional
levels so Dan's going to get into that
here
so if you've decided you wanted to
become certified probably the biggest
hurdle you're gonna face is actually
passing the certification exam so I'd
like to spend a few minutes and just
share some tips and advice for how to
prepare for the exam how to take the
exam and what you should kind of focus
on in terms of domains of knowledge and
topic areas now I'm gonna talk
specifically about the cloud engineering
exam but at least half of what I'm gonna
say applies to any of the exams and a
lot of what I say for the cloud engineer
exam also applies for the architect exam
as well so first of all I want to talk
about a study strategy so if you've just
decided you want to get certified and
you're wondering what's the first thing
I should do I would say go to the
certification page for the certification
certification you're going to take and
find the exam guide Google has done a
really good job of developing a one-page
summary of what's covered on these
certification exams now in the case of
the cloud engineering exam there are
five high level areas and it's things
like planning deploying securing you
know the burbs that Mike was talking
about and for each of those domain areas
there are very specific tasks that you
as a cloud engineer should know how to
do and they get very specific for
example how do you expand a site or
block on a subnet so you have more IP
addresses it's that level of detail that
you need to know when you take this test
so if you're not sure and even if you
are sure you're you're in good shape I
would suggest taking the practice exam
Google has a 20 question practice exam
which is available from the
certification page and they give
detailed explanations of why an answer
is correct or incorrect so it's really
helpful to identify your weak areas
oh and one last thing if there's it them
if I say nothing else probably the most
important thing is that whatever the
tasks are and however familiar you are
you are with certain things it's
important that you actually have
hands-on experience so I would say get
into the cloud she'll get into the cloud
console and do these tasks manually this
is not the kind of an exam that you can
pass by just reading a book or reading
documentation now if you haven't been in
school a while you haven't taken an exam
in a while you might wonder what its
gonna be like well the exams are all
online there are multiple choice 15
questions you have two hours to take the
exam and one of the nice things is that
you can go back it's you're not locked
out once you submit an answer so you can
mark questions for review you can go
back we read things over and I find
that's really helpful when I take the
exams I kind of blow through the ones I
know right away and the ones I'm gonna
have to read and think about a little
bit I go back for and then the key thing
about taking the exam is it's really
important to read the question carefully
now I assume that every word in that
question means something and what I what
I look for in addition to just
understanding what's the question asking
I'm also looking for are there names of
any services or software that I should
be paying attention to and what are the
technical requirements so for example if
I see a word like or a software like
Apache spark and then I also see a
reference to customer requirement
wanting a managed service I'm
immediately going to think of data proc
and I'm gonna start looking for answers
that have those one of the things I
found taking these tests these various
tests is that when it's like a four
choice multiple or a poor choice option
I can usually narrow it down pretty
quickly to two options so one of those
is correct and one of them is a
near-miss now what I do at that point is
I will look and figure out exactly what
the difference is between the two
options and then go back to the text of
the question to figure out what's the
distinguishing characteristic and the
requirements that's going to help me
decide between those two so for example
if I've narrowed down the
options to a question say picking a
database and it's gonna be either
datastore or cloud sequel I'll go back
to the text and I'll look for a
requirement that says something about
maybe a flexible schema in which case
I'll I looked at data store or if I
require a sequel bento of course I'll
look for cloud sequel now in terms of
what you need to know I think there's
sort of two levels here there's stuff
that you really need to know in depth
and stuff you need to be familiar with
be able to understand at a higher level
so we'll cover both of those so with the
cloud as you probably heard over and
over again it's security first so when
you go into that cloud engineer exam
it's really important that you
understand identity and access
management or I am and networking you
really just have to have that down cold
and for I am the key thing to understand
is that or excuse me the key thing to
understand is the roles and the
permissions and how those are structured
now prior to I am Google had something
called primitive roles so if you've seen
things like owner editor viewer these
very coarse-grained roles those existed
prior to I am so did something called
access scopes they're still around those
are considered privileged in the case of
the roles are considered primitive roles
and it's in general it's best practice
not to use those best practice to use I
am and use fine grained permissions and
roles when you're implementing your
authorization controls on the networking
side of the world it's the key things to
know our virtual private clouds you just
need to understand what those are and
the component structures within them
like subnets and cider blocks which are
used to specify IP address ranges within
the subnets via rules are important to
know also understand different options
when you're working with a hybrid cloud
how are you going to connect your
on-premise network to the Google cloud
and so you want to understand things
like direct peering and VPN
also in terms of things you really need
to know in depth definitely cloud and
storage options excuse me compute and
storage options so with compute engine
you'll you almost certainly want to know
that there when to use preemptable
machines you want to understand what is
an instance group what's an instance
template and why do you use them you'll
want to make sure you understand the
role of load balancers and auto scalars
with the app engine you want to
understand that so platform as-a-service
and that there are two types or two
versions of App Engine now there's one
called standard which is the one that's
been around the longest and that's
basically a language specific sandbox
where you can run your application and
then there's also App Engine flexible
which allows you to bring your own
container so you have much more control
over setting up your runtime environment
kubernetes is really important it's
getting even more important so when you
take the cloud engineering exam make
sure you understand both the G cloud and
the cube control commands that are used
to manage kubernetes also understand
kind of the architecture at a high level
of kubernetes and how it works and
understand the idea that services are
implemented as through deployments and
deployments have are implemented within
pods which run on nodes it's important
to know that kind of thing with regards
to cloud functions those are very short
running pieces of code and they're
really designed for event processing so
if you have a question about a customer
uploading an image to cloud storage or
someone dropping a message on a pub sub
queue and you need to do something in
response to that cloud functions might
be the right option for that now on the
storage side it's it's important to
understand cloud storage in detail a
topic that comes up over and over again
when I breeding various things about
cloud storage is that different kinds of
cloud storage with regards to multi
regional regional near line and cold
line so you want to make sure you
understand what all four of those
categories are when you would use one
versus the other and also you want to
understand the life cycle so for example
you can go from
regional two near line two cold line but
you can't go from cold line back to
regional those are the kinds of things
if you have that kind of information in
mine you understand the restrictions on
various things it can help you answer
questions more quickly because you can
eliminate some of the answer options
cloud pub/sub is a messaging system so
it's important to understand just
messaging structure why it's used with
in micro services and things like that
it's not a complicated topic but it's
definitely worth studying stackdriver
like kubernetes is becoming more and
more important and stackdriver actually
has three main components it's a logging
service it has a trace service and also
a debugger so you want to understand
each of those three and how they're
different and when you would use each of
them now those are the things you really
need to understand on a clip as a cloud
engineer in depth you also need to
understand at a high level all of the
services that are available in Google
cloud so while you wouldn't expect a
cloud engineer to know how to say
optimize a data model in a relational
database or design a document datastore
but you do need to understand when you
would use each of those so for example
if somebody if you hear that you need a
relational database or a sequel is
required you need to know that your
sequel options are cloud sequel cloud
spanner and bigquery and then you
eliminate or excuse me then you can sort
of narrow it down from there in terms of
your options if something requires if
you need relational and global
transactions well then you're going to
use cloud spanner if you're looking to
build the data warehouse is some kind of
analytic application and you want sequel
for data analysts who like to do ad hoc
query then big queries the appropriate
option there so just understand for
example BigTable if you're talking about
IOT or any applications where you need
streaming high volume ingestion low
latency writes that's a great option for
for BigTable now you also want to
understand some of the services that are
used for moving data around
like data flow and data prep and and
then also for manipulating some of the
data and analyzing data like data proc
so Cloud Data proc is the managed
Hadoop's Park Service Cloud dataflow is
Google's Google Cloud simplement ation
of Apache bean it's a sort of a unified
platform for both batch and stream
processing data preps more like an ETL
tool which lets you work with your data
and you know kind of prep that poor for
ingestion data lab is used for data
analysis data exploration and then there
are several others like deployment
manager and developer services which
again you don't need to know in depth
but you just need to understand how they
what they provide and where they fit and
how to choose between them and with that
I'm going to turn it back to my there we
go thanks Anne ok so as I mentioned you
can get cloud certified here next you
can register online with our
certification pages there we've got
testing times listed and the
certification test will happen across
the street over at the Westfield San
Francisco Center and the easiest way to
find any of this information I'm about
to give you is using the Google next
mobile application or the online app
there at cloud dot with Google next
sessions there a new search on
certification after you complete your
exam there's some pretty cool swag that
you can get and you get to go into the
certification lounge which is right
there so if you if you are certified
feel free to go use the certification
lounge tonight and for the rest of the
week we have hands-on labs over there
hand hands-on labs are free labs where
you you can work through an experience
tonight we have late night labs with
beverages included we also have over
next to the hands-on lab area spotlight
labs where you can sort of work through
a lab with an instructor and and if
there's an area that you're having
trouble with sometimes watching an
instructor is helpful to see how they
work through some of the pieces of the
lab also tonight we have four sessions
of our very popular cloud
challenge lab so that's a lab where you
compete to solve problems against the
clock and your and your other
competitors for prizes we're gonna have
four sessions of that and that's pretty
fun so look for cloud hero on your
mobile app finally we do have a couple
of offers for free I think it's is it on
here yeah we have a couple of offers for
free time on quick labs in Coursera so
using those links you can get access to
free Coursera and quick labs for a month
that's pretty awesome if you have any
questions about any of this you can ask
the people over by the spotlight labs
and look kind of give you some pointers
and if there's any time left I think
Dan's gonna be around for questions or I
will too and we'll just kind of stand
over here thank you
[Applause]
[Music]